auf den philippinen floriert ein
illegaler goldhandel mit einem
geschätzten volumen von jährlich 700
millionen dollar
sie sagen schwarzmarkt dazu denn es soll
im dunkeln verborgen bleiben
im hintergrund agieren mysteriöse
geldgeber agenten und käufer die für
ihre geschäfte vor nichts
zurückschrecken
wenn beamte und wir würden etwas von uns
wollen bestechen wir sie
der abbau verwüstet das land
die wiederherstellung wird viele jahre
dauern
sid nach dem werk ohhh lose aus
wir suchen die hintermänner des
illegalen handels
ihnen ist egal wer es verkauft und woher
es kommt sie kaufen es einfach
es ist gier nur hier die reine gier
wir folgen dem handel und der spur des
illegalen goldes tourist zu seinem ziel
in den philippinen
[Musik]
nicht weit östlich von manila an der
pazifik-küste liegt der ort parag alle
die so genannte goldstadt
[Musik]
den ältesten bewohnern zufolge gibt es
in pará kahle seit ewigkeiten viel
goldhaltiges gestein
angeblich hat man vor langer zeit
schätze ausgegraben die in der stadt
vergraben worden waren
auch heute noch gibt es hier
es geht einfach nichts anlage nur dass
wir heute tiefer graben müssen um an
gold zu kommen
während man früher riesigen nuggets an
der oberfläche finden konnte
dieser verschlafene ort beherbergt eine
höchst profitable goldförderung
support
mit mischen auch illegal
der abbau mit kompressoren es beliebt
denn wenn man einen guten treffer landet
bekommt man zwischen 100000 und eine
million pacers 2000 bis 20.000 dollar
als bauarbeiter geht das nicht da
bekommt man 300 bis 400 ps oder sechs
bis acht dollar
wer beim goldabbau auch nur einmal glück
hat kann auf einen schlag millionär
werden
jeremy arbeitet in einer illegalen
goldmine schon sein ganzes leben lang
fast alle hier waschen oder schärfen
gold
es ist für uns alle hier die einzige
einkommensquelle
wir riskieren unser leben für diesen job
was sollen wir sonst tun
die meisten von uns haben nur die
grundschule bis zur sechsten klasse
abgeschlossen
es gibt nicht viele jobangebote für uns
nur so kann ich meine familie am leben
erhalten
vor langer zeit wollte ich ihn
überzeugen in manila zu arbeiten aber
wollte kein bauarbeiter werden
mein cousin stellte ihn als portier ein
aber den job wollte er auch nicht
er ist in goldabbau gewohnt er ist er
damit aufgewachsen
[Musik]
sechsmal pro woche paddelt er in 30
minuten nach pagani bahn
[Musik]
goldabbau kann ich viel glück haben
wenn ich nur einmal glück habe kann ich
reich werden
versteckt in einem mangrovensumpf
befindet sich eine illegale gold
förderstätte
[Musik]
orte wie dieser versorgen den
schwarzmarkt mit gold
schärfer wie jeremy heißen spieler
sie haben keinerlei genehmigungen für
ihre arbeit
sie schärfen dass gold mit kompressor
die weltweit riskanteste methode der
goldförderung
sie ist in den philippinen verboten
bei der kompressor methode verbringen
die schäfer viele stunden unter wasser
um an das unterirdische gold zu kommen
sie atmen durch einen dünnen schlauch
der an einem kompressor
es kann über sieben meter tief runter
gehen die tiefe ist beim tauchen kein
problem für mich
die gruben liegen am fluss fühlen sich
also sofort wieder mit wasser wenn man
auch nur einen meter tief gräbt
im flachen bereich können wir beim
tauchen einen halben tag unter wasser
bleiben
sechs oder sieben stunden später tauchen
wieder auf
trotz des risikos arbeiten sie mit
einfachsten mitteln
die baumwolle packe ich in meine ohren
damit der schleim sie nicht verstopfen
können
als nächstes ist das kopftuch drang
der schlauch kommt um die hüfte
der anschlag ist an einen kompressor
angeschlossen und helft mir unter wasser
zu atmen
nun noch die maske
damit kann ich unter wasser die augen
offen halten
colajanni
es ist stockdunkel und
eisig kalt
wir sehen in der tiefe gar nichts
manchmal werde ich vor einem tauchgang
nervös man weiß ja nie was passiert
wenn die grube einbricht wissen wir
nicht ob wir überleben können und
können sich jeremy nur mit den händen
vor antasten
[Musik]
ebics der krebs nach steinen und packt
sie in einen sack den seine freunde an
der oberfläche dann mit einem seil nach
oben ziehen
rocky steine die gold enthalten kommen
beiseite
ihr einkommen variiert jeden tag
nein wir bekommen kein reguläres gehalt
es hängt einzig und allein von den
gefundenen steinen ab wenn sie gold
enthalten verarbeiten sie es und wir
bekommen unseren anteil
manchmal bekommt jeder von uns 200 ps
aus vier dollar am tag manchmal aber
auch nichts
es kommt vor dass wir nichts aus der
grube fördern können
spieler wie jerry sind am untersten ende
dieser illegalen wertschöpfungskette
über
ihnen stehen die geldgeber sie haben das
saßen
alles hier gehört unsere geldgeber
das essen die hütte das kommt alles von
geldgebern
die geldgeber sind die strippenzieher im
hintergrund
sie sind die köpfe der organisationen
und schrecken nicht davor zurück für
ihre geschäfte auch gesetze zu brechen
wenn beamte und behörden etwas von uns
wollen
verstecken wir sie
[Musik]
in camarines norte in den philippinen
arbeiten die menschen seit jahrzehnten
in illegalen goldminen wie die st
[Musik]
es sind die geldgeber die diese
heimlichen geschäfte im hintergrund
finanzieren
sie stellen das team zusammen und
bestimmen den standort termine
wir haben einen von ihnen aufgespürt
in einem kleinen ort nahe parade
[Musik]
wir geben den schiffern gewissermaßen
alles was sie für den abbau brauchen
geld essen eine grube diese
und auch sonst alles
[Musik]
bei einer anfänglichen investition von
1000 dollar für eine illegale mine kann
ein geldgeber seinen einsatz verdoppeln
wenn er auf goldstück
illegal seien aber die geldgeber haben
keine angst die behörden würden ihre
geschäfte unterbinden manche wurden
bezahlt um wegzuschauen
was ist mit den behörden vor ort stecken
die auch mit drin
[Musik]
das lässt sich nicht vermeiden
sie stellen forderungen an uns
werden beamte und behörden etwas von uns
wollen
bestechen
[Musik]
der mann ihren vorgaben nicht folgt wird
man mit sicherheit verhaftet
irgendwo
wenn kein gold gefunden wird mache ich
verluste
wenn gold gefunden wird mache ich
gewinnen
ganz einfach
wenn ich so arbeiten wir nun einen
gewinn
sobald die steine aus der grube abgebaut
werden werden sie zu einer steinmühle
gebracht und zermahlen
stein mühlen sind der nächste baustein
des goldhandels auf dem schwarzmarkt in
pará kahle finden wir hinter einer
kleinen motorrad werkstatt eine der
illegalen steigen
die geldgeber lassen an orten wie diesem
das gold von den steinen trennen
zuerst kommen die steine in die trommeln
der mühle dort werden die steine
gebrochen und zermahlen
danach waschen wir die raffinierten
steine und fügen quecksilber hinzu
quecksilber ist ein hochgiftiges mit
direkter kontakt kann zu schweren
vergiftungen führen
die arbeiter scheinen sich der gefahr
nicht bewusst zu sein
wir nutzen das quecksilber um an das
geld zu kommen
auch wenn wir keine handschuhe verwenden
es ist sicher alles kein problem
die handhabung des quiksilver es ist in
ordnung wenn man sich danach die hände
wäscht insbesondere vor dem essen
der nächste verarbeitungsschritt ist
genauso gefährlich
durch hitze wird das gold vom
quecksilber getrennt
die quecksilber dämpfe die dabei
entstehen sind das problem wenn man sie
einatmet gelangen sie in den körper
deshalb ist es riskant
wo dort ohne jegliche
sicherheitsvorkehrungen riskieren die
arbeiter lungenerkrankungen für gerade
einmal fünf dollar am tag
das sind zweieinhalb gramm
das hier entspricht etwa unserer
normalen produktion
wir schaffen bis zu zehn gramm an einem
tag
einige von ihnen wird diese
goldgewinnung methode jahre später teuer
zu stehen kommen
jerry arbeitet seit 20 jahren in den
illegalen goldminen von caracalla
seit drei monaten jedoch kann er nicht
mehr arbeiten
ich habe atemprobleme und schmerzen in
der brust und im rücken
ich fühle mich die meiste zeit schwach
und gebrechlich
manchmal kann ich kaum gehen und vor
meinen augen verschwimmt alles
er hat schlimmen husten und klagt über
rückenschmerzen
wir sind also her gekommen damit ein
arzt hin untersuchen kann
[Musik]
kann ich helfen
ich habe schmerzen in brust und rücken
wie fing das an
beim tauchen
[Musik]
er hat sehen schleim in der lunge
hier sieht man zeichen von tuberkulose
liegt wohl an seiner arbeit
sieht nach quecksilbervergiftung aus
bei den gruben kommen ständig
quecksilber blausäure und andere sollen
zum einsatz
das passiert wenn man diese substanzen
zu oft einatmet und ihnen jeden tag
ausgesetzt ist
man ist immer müde und bräuchte mehr
schlaf
[Musik]
das immunsystem wird schwächer anhand
der röntgenaufnahmen und meinem
anfänglichen befund gehe ich hier von
lungentuberkulose aus
sie werden für nachuntersuchungen
wiederkommen müssen
[Musik]
ich empfehle ihnen eine halbjährige
medikamentöse behandlung
wenn wir keine wahl haben und das geld
brauchen muss ich wohl wieder
zurückgehen und arbeiten
ich muss arbeiten um meine kenne zu
unterstützen
wenigstens sie sollen in die schule
gehen können
[Musik]
darum muss ich das leid und die gefahren
beim goldschürfen auf mich nehmen was
mit mir passiert ist egal ich muss
arbeiten damit meine kinder in die
schule können
[Musik]
mein mann ist krank und ich fühle mich
so hilflos
wir müssen uns um sechs kinder kümmern
was mache ich wenn ich ihm verliere
[Musik]
ich weiß er ist stark und wird das
überstehen er ist ein kämpfer
während die schärfer unter den
gesundheitlichen folgen leiden machen
die agenten die mittelsmänner zwischen
geldgebern ufern gewinne
von den schiffern verlange ich für die
raffinierung meistens 50 bis 60 ps also
einen dollar pro gramm gold
das hängt auch von der qualität des
goldes ab und davon wie viele
chemikalien wir für die raffinierung
brauchen nur noch wenig so mache ich
meine
[Musik]
die agenten lassen das gold vor dem
verkauf verarbeiten
das gold wird von ausgebildeten
chemikern in illegalen laboren
verarbeitet
das gold wiegen
1,2 grenzen
dann kommt alles in den topf
das ruhe gold muss von verunreinigungen
befreit werden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir kochen das raffinierte gold und
schmerzen ist bei etwa 1000 grad
das raffinierte gold kocht schon
[Musik]
das ist gut
ich nehme das gold
und halte es ins wasser
und jetzt ist es fertig
beinahe 24 karat gold
das raffinierte gold ist nun fertig für
den verkauf
aber wer kauft in pará kahle das illegal
abgebaute gewalt
der philippinischen para kahle wird seit
jahrzehnten illegal gold abgebaut die
schärfe riskieren für gerade einmal fünf
dollar am tag ihr leben
geldgeber und agenten viel grössere
gewinne machen
in diesen scheingeschäften wird das
illegale gold gehandelt
ich bringe üblicherweise das gold das
ich von den schöpfern kaufe hier her
wir folgen dem agenten mit versteckter
kamera an den ort an dem er das gold
verkauft
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dieser käufer hier bietet viel höhere
preise als es die meisten anderen tun
nach außen hin ist es ein computerladen
aber im hintergrund wird gold gehandelt
sie hat man wenn der laden ist sehr
beliebt und denn egal wie viel gold man
bringt sie zahlen immer prompt und in
bar
[Musik]
[Applaus]
den käufern ist es eigentlich egal woher
das geld kommt sie wissen dass es aus
der umgebung ist
ist es den käufern nicht wichtig ob das
gold aus illegalen quellen stammt
sie wissen genau bescheid es kümmert sie
noch nicht
ihnen ist es egal wer es verkauft oder
wo es herkommt
sie kaufen einfach
die spieler am unteren ende der
hierarchie verdienen gerade einmal fünf
dollar am tag die agenten hingegen oft
mehr als zehnmal soviel bei einem
einzigen geschäfte
ich habe gerade gold für 9000 ps gekauft
etwa 180 dollar
der kurs ist glücklicherweise gestiegen
ich konnte es für fast 11.700 pesos
verkaufen etwa 230 dollar und habe heute
2750 dollar verdient
es geht nur ums geld wenn man gold hat
und verkauft ist das sofortiger gewinn
den käufern ist es egal sie zahlen und
man geht wieder ganz einfach
[Musik]
[Applaus]
da so viele mitmachen wollen hinterlässt
der illegalen abbaus tiefe spuren in der
landschaft
[Musik]
die umweltfolgen sind gewaltig
die wiederherstellung wird viele jahre
dauern
[Musik]
der umweltaktivist al konträrer kommt
aus paraquay
[Musik]
hier sehen wir die verlassenen minen
nach dem goldabbau mit der kompressor
methode
wie sie sehen ist alles verwüstet
die masten
bei der kompressor methode wird erdreich
und gestein abgebaut und nicht wieder
aufgefüllt
wenn sie mit dem abbau fertig sind
verlassen sie die stelle und machen eine
neue grube auf wo sie dasselbe wieder
tun
darum ist dieser ort so verwüstet
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bei der kompressor methode wird
quecksilber zur goldgewinnung verwendet
darf quecksilber vergiftet die fische
die wissenschaft warnt vor den folgen
wenn menschen dann diese fische essen
sie haben dann ein erhöhtes risiko dass
ihre kinder mit behinderungen geboren
werden
das recht unseres volkes auf eine
saubere und gesunde umwelt sollte das
hauptaugenmerk sein
china lopez ist umweltaktivist
früher war sie ministerin für umwelt und
natürliche rohstoffe
sie kämpft seit langem gegen den
goldabbau in den philippinen und wirft
der branche umweltzerstörung vor allem
lässt von umweltzerstörung in einem
bereich zu vernichtet man chancen für
andere gebiete
das ökosystem bricht zusammen wie ein
kartenhaus
nicht mehr bauern und fischer sind
betroffen auch die die aktuellen gold
verdienen irgendwann ist alles gold
abgebaut was dann was wird aus ihrer
zukunft das land bis dann tot
am besten wäre es die rohstoffe der
philippinen nachhaltig zu nutzen damit
sie dauerhaft erhalten bleiben und
sollte es nicht jetzt auf kosten der
zukunft zerstören
meiner meinung nach trägt die
hauptschuld an dieser art des goldabbaus
die regierung
die kontrollen reichen nicht aus es nur
zu verbieten reicht nicht die menschen
sind arm sie brauchen alternativen
man muss ihnen eine chance bieten und
sie begleiten
wer muss sicher stellen dass alles
korrekt läuft
die regierung muss sicherstellen dass
nichts illegales geschieht
die regierung wo ist der muss
sicherstellen dass die arme nicht leiden
die regierung handelt die regierung nur
zum wohle der reichen was bleibt den
armen
[Musik]
viele illegale schärferes kern weiterhin
ihr leben und ihre gesundheit für ihre
familien
[Musik]
meine hände sind so geworden seit ich in
den offenen gruben schärfe
der abbau mit bloßen händen unter wasser
hat meine hände und fingernägel staat
beschädigt
die hände tun sehr weh aber mit genug
ruhe und medizin erholen sie sich und
die nägel wachsen wieder
apollo will nicht dass sein sohn das
gleiche durchmachen muss
ich hoffe er setzt sich andere ziele wie
zb im ausland zu arbeiten
darum strenge ich mich umso mehr an wenn
ich nicht genug geld verdienen
ich arbeite hart damit er seine bildung
bekommt
[Musik]
china lopez glaubt der illegale
goldabbau habe seine grundlage nicht nur
in der armut
ihr zufolge kommt das problem von ganz
oben
einige in der regierung hätten großes
interesse am goldabbau
gouverneure abgeordnete ihre familien
betreiben den goldabbau
meine güte
manche der abgeordneten im kongress
hinter dem goldabbau beteiligt
auf den philippinen werden wahlkampagnen
durch den goldabbau finanziert
wenn man einen politiker finanziert
schuldete einem etwas
politiker entscheiden immer wieder
zugunsten geschäftliche interessen auch
wenn die rechte der bürger dabei
verletzt werden
das ist wirklich schlimm
[Musik]
während die agenten in kleinem rahmen an
örtliche geschäfte verkaufen agieren die
verkäufer in größerem maßstab sie kaufen
und verkaufen gold in großen nehmen
[Musik]
wir haben eine verkäuferin gefunden
sie zeigt uns wo das illegale gold
üblicherweise verkauft wird
[Musik]
ich kaufe das gold von den spielern und
lasse es danach raffinieren
dann bringe ich es direkt nach biondo in
manila
[Musik]
ich sage schwarzmarkt dazu denn er soll
ja verborgen bleiben
man will beim goldkauf nicht erkannt
werden darum sage ich schwarzmarkt dazu
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir folgen der spur des illegalen goldes
von rak alle
nach manila
geht das in die zentralbank wird es
irgendwann in der zentralbank landen
oder im ausland
wer weiß wo es landet
[Musik]
im philippinischen para kahle wird
illegal gold abgebaut
das meiste gold landet jedoch 350
kilometer entfernt
in dem china town manilas
gibt es viele seriöse goldhändler
doch unseren quellenpark alle zufolge
kaufen einige händler in london in
großem stil illegal abgebautes kalt
goldproduzenten auf den philippinen sind
per gesetz verpflichtet es an die
zentralbank zu verkaufen
viele handeln aber lieber auf diesen
schweiz markt
ich gehe nicht gern zur zentralbank es
gibt so viele auflagen
außerdem schmettern steuern und gebühren
dort meinen gewinnen
ich gehe lieber gleich auf den
schwarzmarkt
mit versteckter kamera versuchen wir mit
einem käufer auf dem schwarzmarkt
zufrieden
seid ihr bereit bereit
läuft die aufnahme ja
[Musik]
ein mann erscheint uns verdächtig
wir nähern uns und geben uns als
goldverkäufer aus
brauchen wir keine dokumente
er ist einer der agenten
wir brauchen wirklich keine dokumente
nicht hier
schwarzmarkt händler kaufen hier oft
gold ohne die herkunft mittels
dokumenten zu prüfen so vorzugehen ist
in den philippinen
nehmen sie auch gold aus park alle an
natürlich die nehmen alles
ist ihnen egal wo es herkommt
der agent will und seinem boss
vorstellen einem großen goldkäufer
er war mal polizist es ist also alles in
ordnung wenn ihr wirklich viel gold habt
wird er euch sicher einladen
er macht nicht gern draußen geschäfte
kommt mit ich zeig euch keine sorge er
wird euch bezahlen geht einfach rein ich
sag bescheid dann macht ihr drin in
euren handel
[Musik]
sein boss wartet in einer ruhigen ecke
hinter einigen seriösen
juweliergeschäften
[Musik]
was ist das hier gold
24 karat
nehmen sie auch große mengen mit
dokumentation
müssen sie beim goldkauf keine papiere
prüfen
[Musik]
hier nicht
ich dachte es wäre wie bei der
zentralbank ich bin nicht die
zentralbank ich mache das zum ersten mal
das gold kommt aus der provinz
wie soll ich es bewährten
programm
programm was ist der preis
wie wäre es mit 2000
2000 pesos geht das in die zentralbank
wird es irgendwann in der zentralbank
landen oder im ausland wer weiß wo es
landet
[Musik]
der käufer wird misstrauisch und bricht
den handel ab
wir ziehen uns zurück bevor wir auf
liegen
[Applaus]
schätzungen zufolge wurden 2012 90
prozent des goldes aus kleinen
abbaustätten in den philippinen auf dem
schwarzmarkt gehandelt und ins ausland
verkaufen
es ist hier nur hier
die reine gier
niemand braucht das gold wir brauchen
wasser essen wir brauchen luft es ist
falsch dass die regierung im namen der
gier das leben unseres volkes gefährdet
es verstößt gegen die verfassung
manchem hat die gier nach gold das leben
unwiederbringlich zerstört
[Musik]
am morgen des 21 november ist 2012 waren
wir beim frühstück alle gut gelaunt
dann sagte man müsse jetzt zur arbeit
gehen muss wäre das geld ausgegangen
er sagte er müsse zur arbeit aber zuerst
wollte er noch gemeinsam essen also
sollte ich kochen
ich machte frühstück und wir alle maßen
glücklich miteinander
erst um vier uhr nachmittags wurde mir
klar dass das unser letztes gemeinsames
frühstück sein würde auch für unsere
kinder
an diesem tag stürzten die minen von
baradei palmas ein wobei julis mann und
drei weitere schiffe bei der arbeit
unter tage zu tode kamen
es war sehr schmerzhaft denn er war
besonders süß gewesen an diesem tag
das mir buchstäblich das herz und ich
wünschte die welt würde enden damit ich
ihm folgen könnte
[Musik]
der investor juli geld im austausch für
ihr schweigen
gebot mehr 100.000 pesos etwa 2.000
dollar damit ich schweige und er
versicherte mir dass man den leichnam
eines mannes bergen würde
der geldgeber nahm alle kosten auf sich
hielt aber die medien fern aus angst er
müsse seine miene schließen
da sie die familie nicht anders ernähren
konnte und am juli das geld an
die entscheidung fiel mir nicht leicht
ich war zuerst wütend mein mann war in
ihrer grube gestorben
ich war hin und hergerissen wegen des
geldes
100.000 für das leben eines mannes was
sollte ich aber tun es war zu spät sie
konnten wir meinen mann nicht
zurückgeben
wer so die behörden suchten nach dem
geldgeber der mine konnten ihn aber
nicht finden somit wurde niemand für das
unglück zur rechenschaft gezogen
[Musik]
noch heute wird juli von der tragödie
verfolgt
[Musik]
meine kinder und ich vermisse ihn sehr
manchmal muss ich an ihn denken
besonders nachts
ich bete dafür nur für einen moment mit
ihm und den kindern wieder vereint zu
sein
heute tut es mir weh zu akzeptieren dass
er nicht mehr bei uns ist
dem unglück folgt der eine umfangreiche
untersuchung der gefahren der kompressor
methode
die folge war ein landesweites verbot
des goldabbaus in kleinem maßstab
[Musik]
doch in pará kahle geht der illegale
goldabbau weiter
seit 2012 starben dabei mindestens zehn
weitere schärfer
allen verboten zum trotz wird der abbau
in den kleinen minen weitergehen da die
gesetze nicht durchgesetzt werden und es
keine alternativen gibt
[Musik]